we know the ps4 neo is real and we know  that it's a more powerful version of  Sony's current console but when will we  finally see it in action I'm Tony and  this is your investigative gamespot news  update reports from both game blog and  vice have surfaced claiming the neo will  be revealed at an event in New York on  Wednesday September 7th this would put  the reveal about a week before Tokyo  Game Show kicks off on the 15th no  further details were mentioned but if  this information is accurate invitations  for the reveal should be going out soon  fingers crossed other reports say the  ps4 neo could release by the end of the  year if that's true then the official  reveal can't be too far away but with  the announcement of Microsoft's project  Scorpio Sony's plans may have been  interrupted stay tuned to gamespot as  the story develops and for all the  biggest PlayStation news you're already  in the right place  you